i would have these conversations that
were confusing to me where you would be
debating a so-called liberal
and i would be and i would find myself
taking the liberal side like in favor of
free speech
or you might default suspicion of
corporate power or concentrations of
power anywhere because it's a threat to
the individual or in favor of due
process or you know i would take a
position that
i heard liberals of my childhood take
and the liberal i'm debating would be
like nope you know if google says that
it's true
or you know if you're accused prove
yourself innocent or if what you say is
offensive you don't have right to say
it'll be like wait a second this is a
mirror image of what i grew up with so
actually to answer your question as
honestly as i can i don't know if they
ever really meant what they said
dr carlson welcome to the reuben hey
dave
i am glad to have you here my friend i'm
glad to be here i love this i don't know
that anyone has ever walked in here have
been more impressed by the ruby because
i work in television so i know what this
is and it's just the coolest thing i've
seen in a long time are you jealous
are you joking yes i'm jealous you have
millions and millions of viewers i drive
across you have a massive staff
but i don't have the control that you
have which is wonderful yeah control all
right so speaking of control i have only
one goal for the next hour which is to
some point say something so ludicrous
that you stare at me with that face
where i may do that
where did the face come it's totally
everyone the memes that come out totally
organic the funny thing is when i mean
that's just my face at rest which is
golden retriever-like yeah i'm a mouth
breather and when i first started this
show
um i got complaints about it internally
and the idea was it's too embarrassing
click [ __ ]
um
but i can't stop i can't help myself so
i'm not a super self-aware person i'm
not a mirror user for example because if
you work in tv and you become really
self-conscious it destroys you yeah and
makes you insecure so i just am trained
after 20 years not to think about the
way i look
and
i didn't even know that i look like a
[ __ ]
but i do
and i'm not changing well i know you're
not bsing because even just now when you
were in the green room and my girl was
putting makeup on you you sat there for
literally two seconds you were like
don't do anything you didn't even look
at the mirror you were looking at me and
you can go crazy as you know in tv if
you start to think about how other
people perceive you
you just drown in like me you know and i
don't want that all right so i'm glad to
have you here for for a couple reasons
we're going to get into the book and
obviously we're kind of simpatico on
what i think are the big issues of the
day related to free speech all that
stuff but i will be totally honest with
you years ago when i first saw you on uh
crossfire on cnn
i was not a fan now i was now you
weren't alone in that i thought here's
this bow tie wearing guy who was you
know seemingly kind of smug and whatever
and i was a lefty at the time so so we
were really polar opposites politically
yeah but everything has shifted enough
that that we are kind of allies now and
i actually think that's that's kind of
cool so before we do anything else
tell me about little tucker carlson
people know about tucker carlson that
eviscerates socialists all day what was
i like as a kid yeah well i grew up here
in southern california and um we lived
in studio city
and i mean i think i've always been the
same anti-authoritarian
for the individual against the group
um i hate bullies i hate being bullied
more than anything and so if you i found
myself and i've always been this way
in a scenario where everyone is forced
to sort of nod in bovine agreement about
something my instinct is always to be
the one guy who's like no
and um so i haven't changed at all the
particulars of my political beliefs have
changed because america has changed so
dramatically i'm 49 so in the last 40
years it's become a different country
and a lot of the things that i thought
would work haven't worked a lot of
things i thought were not threatening
turned out to be threatening so you know
my views have changed but my instincts
have remained
i think consistent over time yeah were
you always political or were your
parents that was always political yeah
well i was always interested in history
and my father was a non-uh conformist
i would say
i mean that's an understatement
and his baseline position was just
because everybody says it doesn't mean
it's true
and the answers to the way
people are are found in history because
the one immutable fact of history is
human nature like it literally does not
change and you see consistent themes
over time and so if you want to
understand what's happening look
backward
and you will i mean just pretty
conventional stuff but now it sounds
kind of radical but um
basically my main influence was my dad i
grew up with my dad and my brother and
again his view was you know just because
all the chin tuggers are saying it
does not prove it yeah does that seem
like a pretty obvious through line to
your success right now because it's like
every day there is some other group
thing exactly lunacy that it's like
these people then go on your show and i
always think it's hilarious because it's
like do they know what they're getting
into do you're you know what it's like
yeah because i think they're going to
beat you and
well but they don't actually have the
same goals for the debate that i do
so i'm linear and literal and
old-fashioned and i go into it you know
believing that i can win the person over
um with
superior reasoning or you know larger
and more compelling fact set or whatever
they're coming to this believing they've
already won because they have superior
virtue so they're having a theological
conversation i'm having a political
debate and too often we talk right past
each other yeah that's interesting a
theological conversation a couple a
couple of people have mentioned on the
show my friend peter bogosian who's a
philosophy professor who's been on a few
times he calls this sort of new leftism
a secular religion of course do you view
that look i'm an episcopalian so i know
what happened because the episcopal
church was the church of them of
america's ruling class
our national cathedral's an episcopal
church
so our culture was rooted in mainline
protestantism this was a protestant
country
and our rulers whether they were like
literally protestant or not internalized
the values
of that faith and then within like a
20-year period the faith evaporated the
episcopal church barely exists
anymore and certainly is a national
force it's irrelevant but that didn't
eliminate the religious impulse within
people which is inherent it's innate
we're born that way we worship something
in the end
whether you know it doesn't need to be
god um and so they've transferred
that religious impulse to the political
sphere they're making the same arguments
that
19th century protestants made especially
the calvinists like i am saved like i
know this that's my baseline assumption
i'm one of god's elect you are not
if you go into any conversation like
that
nothing will be resolved because because
it's already been decided yeah well it's
it's good versus evil
exactly that's exactly what it is yeah
was it always like this though no it
wasn't like so what what give me give me
some markers of when you saw things kind
of start to change i mean i'm kind of
you know i'm not an intellectual i'm a
talk show host so
a little well now we have our promo clip
well it's it's true i mean that's what i
do
um
so it took me a while to see the outline
i mean this all comes kind of slowly to
me because i'm caught in an earlier time
just by virtue of my age and so i would
have these conversations that were
confusing to me where you would be
debating a so-called liberal
and i would be and i would find myself
taking the liberal side like in favor of
free speech
or
my default suspicion of corporate power
or concentrations of power anywhere
because it's a threat to the individual
or in favor of due process or you know i
would take a position that
i heard liberals of my childhood take
and the liberal i'm debating would be
like nope you know if google says that
it's true
or you know if you're accused prove
yourself innocent or if what you say is
offensive you don't have right to say it
i'll be like wait a second this is a
mirror image of what i grew up with so
actually to answer your question as
honestly as i can i don't know if they
ever really meant what they said i
really don't it's possible that the
pursuit of power and the empowerment of
the democratic party was always the goal
and that was just the disguise they used
in order to achieve it in 1979 i don't
know the answer yeah would do you think
we'd be in a healthier situation if
there was
a sane democratic party even if all the
policies were against everything that
carlson believes yeah that's the point
of my book the feng shui is off
so for like a hundred years you had one
party which was the corporate party the
republican party the country club party
the party of the ruling class
and the other party existed in effect to
keep it in check and to say wait a
second you know you're getting rich
because all these people are working
really hard
you need to think about their interests
and a bunch of different things happen
the value of labor dropped
because of technology to the point where
it's not even worth representing the
working class because they're not worth
anything actually that this was the
calculation of the democratic party
and so basically what you have is this
weird alignment where the leadership of
the republican party represents
corporate interests and leadership the
democratic party represents corporate
interests
and there's no one to represent the
middle class and that again the balance
is off you need a vigorous party
standing up and saying well wait a
second you need balance always you need
balance yeah so is that the part of this
that's sort of scary for our future and
that's kind of what you're going for in
the book is that if one side completely
implodes which it seems more likely as
we're taping this at the moment that the
democrats are yes going to absolutely
implode that it's not as if all the
conservative policies that you might
like would suddenly take root it's that
we would actually tilt in some really
bizarre exactly that's exactly right i
mean this is why marriage is an
institution works because there's like
another person
pushing back against your bad instincts
or balancing you out you know
and what's true at home is probably true
on a national scale on a political scale
and yes you absolutely need a vigorous
and principled opposition party always
or else you've got something really ugly
then you've got the monoparty which is
kind of what we have yeah you know
jordan peterson who i know you admire
also one of the lines when he's talking
about politics it's interesting you
brought up marriage he'll always say you
know it's like a fight with your spouse
you don't want to beat them because then
you're married to a loser you want to
give them a chance
to figure out something so that you'll
be able to move forward and we seem at
this we're at this odd place right now
where it's like one side is trying to
beat the other side the other side is
trying to beat the other side and the
rest of us which i think is actually
most of us are just like
that's true you don't want to beat your
spouse because you're married to a loser
but you're also a loser if you're
married to a loser the point is you're
implicated in the future of the other
side because in the end you're all in
this together even though you're coming
from it from different perspectives so
you're we're all americans
so in the same way that crushing your
spouse doesn't actually
win you any kind of meaningful victory
or victory you'd want
crushing your fellow americans
doesn't
improve your life or your country so
like you know you don't want any of this
it's going to lead to something really
bad actually really ugly and everybody
who's paying any kind of attention
senses it on an animal level this is
this is moving in a really ominous
direction a lot of people are getting
their news
from this from this show shows like this
shapiro rogan all of these guys that's
kind of worrying too at some level right
and i say that i'm talking about guys
that i love but like
just that you know the fact checking is
different here than say it would be on
cable news not that
cable news has done a great job no but
you're right i mean we're part you know
we're
we're always a point on a continuum and
we're in the middle of a cycle
where the media are being reinvented
completely and
you're right i mean the problem with
individual operators solo guys on
youtube is they have so much less to
lose than a television network does that
the incentives to get the facts ready to
be responsible of course much lower
the problem as you well know better than
anybody is that the media have so
discredited themselves that it's like
it's so obviously propaganda yeah but
did you ever think it could be that bad
no i never bad as it is now where every
day i look at a story from cnn or
politico and forget buzzfeed and
all those other like forget the really
bad ones
vox and it's like everything you guys
are doing every headline the way every
republican has a picture that they look
awful in the picture democrats look
great like every little thing
it's like they're just smashing us with
it they've just turned it up to 11. and
i've i mean i grew up in a media family
i mean my dad was anchor here in l.a of
abc and so i i've always lived in this
world and i always thought the media are
liberal but i was totally wrong about
that they're not audio logs actually
they're party people that's what i
totally missed yeah they are loyal to
the party they feel powerless except as
part of a group that is the main
distinction between left and right in
this country and so whatever the
democratic party's imperatives are they
will act on them if the democratic party
invaded canada
tomorrow you would see i'm serious
they'd be like you know these canadians
they live among us they're you know what
i mean they're a fifth column like they
would actually it doesn't matter what
the party does they will defend it once
you understand that then it all makes
sense they feel threatened that's the
truth and you and people like you are
the main threat to them it's not me
actually i'm on a competing medium but
in the same
medium
they are
they know that their power is ebbing and
when you feel like you're losing control
that's when you try to assert control
yeah that's when the most ludicrous
propaganda comes when you feel like you
know oh my gosh they're not listening to
me i have to yell but that's the funny
part is i always i tweet this all the
time it's like if these guys had just
been like pretty bad yeah i think it
would have been tolerable people would
have because it had been happening for
so long people kind of wouldn't have
noticed and maybe they could have got a
little worse and we would have been okay
with it but it's like they've just
completely
bottomed out and well this is one of the
the criticisms of trump that has a lot
of truth in it when people are like well
he's a destroyer he destroys everything
he touches
you know
probably an overstatement but he does
you know you get close you sit and stare
at trump all day
and you're gonna burn out your retinas
okay you are and that's one of the
things i try not to do i don't do a show
about trump i didn't write a book about
trump yeah i'm not against trump i think
trump is useful and a truth teller in
some ways but but the people who obsess
about trump are destroyed
and that would include his opponents
maybe especially his opponents so what
would you do to get some of those people
back if they're if they're out there now
the ones that really are overboard on
trump that i haven't you know i've been
able to reach some some liberals some
good lefties and liberals so that okay
we can put a hand out for them but for
the people that are really feeling like
they're buying all the nonsense right is
hitler and all of this really
do you have any technique that gives you
sure i mean i almost never argue about
trump i really try not to i mean the
platonic ideal for me of a show is never
mentioning trump because i try to take
the long view i mean look other shows
have different roles you know everybody
sees like you know his or her specific
task but i feel like mine is to try to
take the long view not easy in the
middle of this news cycle of course i
get caught up all the time in the you
know the [ __ ] of the day but but mo
but i really try
to think about like well how would this
look 10 years from now like trump will
be gone i'll be gone we'll all be gone
because we actually die at the end it
turns out so but i want the country to
continue 10 years
but i'm just saying like what kind of
country do you want that's the question
do you want to live in a place where the
individual has the right to dissent and
i think most people would say yes i do
yeah is that why the free speech stuff
has become so important to you well i
think because that is more than
foundational i mean that's just if they
can tell you what to say
they can control what you think and if
they can control what you think you're
not fully human and so you're really
you're not fighting for a political
party or an ideology or fighting for
your humanity i believe that that's what
i was taught as a child by liberals and
they were right and i bought it then by
the way and so the aclu stood up for
clarence brandenburg who was not only
literally a klansman from ohio but a
[ __ ] like literally a [ __ ] he was the
least appealing person ever and they
staked their entire credibility on
defending this guy why'd they do that
they did it of course to preserve the
absolute right of free speech for the
rest of us and they made the country
better when you abandoned that yeah dude
it's over and now you see what comes out
of the aclu and you're like you're not
you're not defending free speech you're
clearly a progressive
group they're opposing friends
they issued a statement saying you know
some speeches is too offensive really
because you defended the right of nazis
to march through skokie which everyone
forgets had the highest percentage of
holocaust survivors of any town like
outside israel yeah i mean it was the
most defensive thing you could do and
they defended it and they lost a lot of
money doing it like they lost a ton of
donations doing it but they defended the
principal and i noticed you've got an
idiot strawson's book yeah we talked
right there so there are people like her
or dershowitz or these former aclu board
members who were like totally bewildered
by this not because we care about the
aclu as an institution who cares it's
some dumb non-profit but because the
principles
are are literally foundational yeah all
right so let's let's jump back for just
a second here so i want to talk about
fox generally yeah so first off
you guys are doing something right and i
don't mean just you here clearly if you
look at the ratings i just looked at
this thing and it's like the last bottom
20 shows are all cnn yeah the top 10 are
basically all fox maybe there's one
msnbc show in there
beyond just you what do you what do you
think that fox is just doing right
you know being slightly different
i mean i you know i would argue that
i mean i can only speak for my show i'm
only in charge of an hour of
24 but
you know that it's actually worth
defending the principles as distinct
from the individuals or the political
figures and over time like you're not
embarrassed to do that it's worth doing
but i think as a business matter and
just sort of a matter of life if you're
the guy who's not entirely with the herd
and you're like actually no i it's a
little bit different you know you go to
the 19 other stores and you can buy this
one product and i've got a different
product i mean why is that bad yeah so
that just seems obvious but what's so
interesting is how offensive that is
yeah it's like fog and i've worked i've
worked at cnn i've worked at msnbc i
worked at pbs i worked at esquire i mean
i've worked at like a million different
liberal publications and television
channels and they're all selling exactly
the same product and then there's fox
in the mainstream landscape
that's different just one channel is
different
and the the feeling overwhelming feeling
is that should not be allowed like i
can't believe that they're allowed to
say what they're saying we need to shut
them down well that's the irony it's
like you guys are the only ones that
will put me on i will gladly go on cnn
you can't get on those channels i've
never been asked i can't just show up
there and bang on the door but you guys
call me and nobody every time i've done
your show it's live i never know what
you're going to have of course and and
same thing with some of the other shows
and it's like
i will go where i can talk to people
i don't i don't want to be edited and
misrepresented which so i don't know
that i would trust a lot of these other
people no um okay so that's sort of what
but it's just so uninteresting i mean if
everybody's saying repeating the exact
same pieties diversity is our strength
our children are our future or whatever
the sort of banality is that you think
is profound if everybody is saying the
exact same thing like that's just boring
i like to have i like to have people on
who surprise me like what
do you know what i mean like that just
because again
i'm more curious i mean i'm a human
being i i want to think about things
does it ever drive you crazy to just be
in the in the constraints of what
television is you know like because
we've done segments where it's like you
know we've got maybe six minutes and i
feel like i just started and then you're
like reuben i'll see you next time you
know yeah i mean i was a writer before i
went into tv and one of the reasons that
i failed a couple of times pretty
spectacularly in tv is because i didn't
understand the medium and i didn't
respect it i was like i'm a writer i'm a
deep person here i am in the shallow
medium and what i didn't understand is
that tv is it's complete it's a
completely different thing yeah and it's
got its own requirements and its own
rules and
you need to understand what it's capable
of and it's capable of great things it's
just not capable of everything you know
what i mean it's not capable of
explaining concept complex concepts just
that's not what tv's about someone's for
tucker you are not in your studio you're
not in a suit you appear to be in some
sort of secret bunker area with books
and pictures what's going on over there
i'm in a i'm in my barn actually to be
totally honest which is where i work i
live in a rural area in northern new
england and we have an old barn that we
use for
everything basically to store the boats
and
my wife has her peloton and we have our
studio in it and you know bunk beds for
people and so yeah i live in my barn
so you're kind of living the dream that
you always wanted in a way i mean a
couple years ago i've quoted this many
times quoted you actually many times you
walked into my house opened the door to
my garage and i don't know if fox news
is going to want me to say the exact
thing you said but you basically said
holy effin [ __ ]
you've done it meaning that i had a
studio at home and i was able to run my
operation you you've kind of expanded
into that world while still maintaining
the mainstream cred
what yeah i mean
i have to say i've always believed that
what matters is how you live you know
what's your what's your life like what
do you do when you wake up what time do
you wake up who do you wake up with i
mean those are the things that define
your life
and so when i saw how you lived i
thought man
this guy is really i mean i know people
who make a ton of money
who don't live anywhere near as well as
you do and i was just so impressed by
that and um of confluence of events
happened and
what i mean we actually live in the town
that we've been in our whole lives so
it's not we didn't move anywhere weird
we this is where you know we had a house
here always growing up but
um
why not just move there and so we did
and it's been wonderful
yeah and you were dealing with some
headaches living in some other places
because you know obviously the media
matters people and all the usual trolls
and everything they were sending people
to your house and right you know going
out i mean literally like going after
your wife and kids and all that i know
it's not fun to talk about that but can
you just talk about it a little bit just
sort of relative to you're just trying
to do what you think is right as a as a
journalist and as a personality and then
how it affects the the life and the
people around you yeah i mean it was
just sad to see it happen i moved to
washington as a kid my dad worked for
the federal government and um on the
cold war and doing pretty honorable
things i would say i think that anyway
and um so i've lived in washington
essentially my whole adult life i mean
since high school and it's a bipartisan
town i mean by definition both parties
are represented both parties live there
and as a result there's been this
permanent truce effectively for decades
where you can live next to people you
disagree with but you don't talk about
it at dinner parties you can be friends
anyway and i love that environment a lot
of my friends had politics different
from mine
and then
in 2016 trump was such a threat they
were so worried not that trump would
actually do anything any and he really
didn't as
as we know
but he said stuff and he said obvious
stuff and they were so terrified that
trump was going to point out some really
obvious things about the way things
actually work
that they were completely threatened by
i mean really threatened by him it was
like a foreign power occupying the city
and the hatred the bitterness
and i just kind of agreed with a lot of
trump's i don't know ideas may be a
little strong but themes
you know like when you run the
government you should always ask
yourself is this helping the people who
live here who voted for me who pay for
all of this whose country it is
i really agree with that i always have
so um
that the division in the city between
the overwhelming majority of people who
saw trump as this satanic figure and the
tiny minority of us who were like well
yeah okay trump
whatever
you know he's got all these personal
faults got it but he's making really
good points like what is the point of
nato for let me just pick one of a
thousand examples why shouldn't we have
a border wall you know what about all
those people who died of fentanyl like
what's the answer
and all of a sudden it just became
impossible to live there and then
you know i've never lived behind a gate
or anything we lived right on the street
in the city all that raised my kids my
four kids there and all of our dogs and
all this stuff and i felt like we were
really part of the city and then
next thing you know people are showing
up at the house and you can sort of see
where this is going you know it's so
threatening
you know where does it end you're going
to wind up shooting somebody and i i
don't want to do that you know i hate
but that's that's where it's going you
know because just living there was so
provocative to them
having them show up and threaten
violence against my family was so
threatening to me
that it just it wasn't going to end well
and i just thought
and our fourth child went off to
boarding school
and we didn't have any kids at home and
so we're like well wait you know why
don't we just move to where we already
spent the summer so we did
yeah so do you think that the people
that you're talking about
there that are sort of the permanent dc
class and the swamp as trump would call
them do you think it's a
conscious decision that they're always
existing to keep themselves in that
power or is it just that you just get
there and then before you know it you're
just in this thing and and you like
what's happening so you just stay in
that thing so that's why he was the
threat to it and i would argue that in a
weird way you now that trump has stepped
away a lot of the hatred that was just
always directed towards trump is now
directed more towards you because you're
carrying the torch for some of those
ideas yeah i mean i'm not
totally aware of that i i have a kind of
peripheral sense that i'm disliked by
some people but you know i don't i don't
have a television i don't i don't go on
the internet i don't use social media
i'm pretty i'm pretty insulated from
that stuff because why would i literally
you literally don't i know you don't
check twitter but you literally don't
have a television oh no i've never had
it i've never had a tv no
no no i just didn't you know i didn't
grow up like that and my dad worked in
tv when i was a kid and he was
he was pretty pro reading i would say he
was a militant reading person so yeah we
had a lot of enforced reading in our
house and so yeah that's how i grew up
but um
yeah but mostly you know i i have a very
close circle of friends and i have a big
family and i'm really close to my wife
and my producers who i absolutely love
my executive producer i'm really close
to them so i have a lot of people around
me
who will tell me the truth and do
um if they think i'm being a douche or
i'm crossing some line or whatever
they'll just say it they're not afraid
they're not afraid of me at all so
unfortunately um so i
i feel like i've got a pretty good
series of backstops against going
totally crazy
and so and i really care about their
opinion because these are people i love
and respect
and so my view has always been my whole
life
you know i had a weird childhood which
kind of changed my view on this but
but fundamentally was you should only
care
about the opinions of people who care
about you
and who have you know demonstrated
loyalty and wisdom and an ongoing
relationship why would you ever let
strangers
have control of your emotional state
like that's insane and you know you hear
people say that but i think i'm in the
rare category of people who mean it so i
would never go online and like google
myself why would i do that
no i really i know you mean it
right exactly i i know you mean it
because i think the first time we met in
person i asked you something about the
hate and the twitter mentions and you're
like i don't have twitter like it's you
know it's tucker carlson on twitter
we're like it's not you know i'm not the
one checking it and tweeting this stuff
and that keeps you kind of insulated and
safe and sane it's yeah and and i have a
huge number of people i talk to every
day i mean i spend my whole life talking
to people mostly by text but hundreds of
people and i try to clear my text every
night it was up till two in the morning
in front of the fire where i live it's
cold um on september 1st and uh with my
dogs you know and i'm up really late
banging out these texts taking notes so
i i i speak to a ton of people and not
just people in my world not just famous
rich people but like a lot of random
people
a waitress that i had in big sur i hope
she's watching this i know she's a fan
of yours
years ago
has
i gave her my text for some reason she
and her husband are like such thoughtful
people and she has been texting me ever
since and i swear once a month two
nights ago i used one of her lines on
the air
like at least once a month i'll like run
with the story ideas she sends me so i
have a huge number of people that i
correspond with
but i don't want to open it up to the
mob i mean i because then i can't think
clearly and my whole job is
you know and i don't always pull it off
but i really try to think clearly like
what is going on here you know ascend a
little bit get higher look down
what are the outlines of this and
being involved in this [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
too you know
i don't like noise in my personal life i
like quiet and i don't like noise in my
work or intellectual life you know i
like to i like to think i like nature
you know i like i like hunting and
fishing i like to be outside
i don't want to sit in a room and read
other people's hysteria i don't think
there's any upside to that at all first
off like how bad you think really like
the cnn msnbc new york times wapo
machine is on one hand but on the other
hand just like a little insider stuff on
how you guys go about doing your show on
a daily basis because i know your
producers a little bit and obviously i
go on the show and i find that you do
the show in a way where it's like you're
almost doing like uh it almost feels
more like a book than a tv show where
it's like each day you're doing
something and then you sort of pick up
the next day and pick up the next day
and i'm trying to do something similar
here so that everything doesn't feel
like this disconnected lunacy that that
everyone else in i'm just wondering a
little bit about like the nuts and bolts
about how you guys decide to do what
you're going to do
well i'm a writer so that's that's how i
think you know in terms of chapters and
you know serials this is a story i'm
giving you one installment today another
tomorrow it's just how my brain works
um but it's a practical matter you know
i wake up not too early i hope
and uh with my wife and four dogs i try
and sit outside for a minute get my head
together and then i write out a memo
every morning for the whole staff
on what i think the lead ought to be who
we should book and we've got a whole
pipeline of some unbelievable people who
work
on the show just really really smart i
mean really smart and um
one of the people i talk to a lot so you
know we've had if i can brag the same
staff for five years i think we've lost
one person two people and it's pretty
big staff um
and they're just they're all in they're
so clever they're so creative they're so
interesting but one of our our head tape
guy is a guy called tom fox a guy's
freaking genius
and he really is my window into cable
news like the poor guy is very smart but
he watches all his cables
so he's constantly texting he drinks a
lot i'm guessing
what he drinks a lot i'm guessing i i
don't he seems pretty sober but i mean
maybe he's on pills i don't know
but i like you know
i sit there with my you know stupid
glasses on and my phone and i'm looking
up i honestly can't believe that i
cannot believe they didn't say this
um so basically by like 11 30 in the
morning you know i've sketched out what
i think the show should be in my mind
it's always because again i was a
reporter and a
magazine writer i think in terms of the
lead you know what's
my editor used to say to me when i was
kid get in the lead like but what's the
lead like how do you open it up
you know what's the what's the theme
and i try to
as just a as an exercise that i've
always
um
you know that i learned as a kid and
i've always used sum it up in a sentence
you know what's it about
you know our first segment usually goes
20 25 minutes what's it about one
sentence it's not about eight things
it's about one thing how would you
summarize it and that's a really
helpful organizing principle
for putting it together and then you
know right around five o'clock i try and
take a sauna every day because i think
it's really important
as a scandinavian i'm true to my people
and uh i think about it in the sauna
then i go out i think about it more and
then i sit down around five have a cup
of coffee and i start writing
um the lead and so that's basically it
but
the media stuff is so shocking to me
because i you know i worked at cnn for
years and i posted a couple shows there
several shows there and then i you know
i was the main anchor in msnbc for four
years i got fired
but you know i i still have a really
good friend
who will remain nameless who works there
just a wonderful person really good guy
and i have a couple of friends at cnn so
not a ton too but uh but anyway but i
know that world really really well
and the biggest surprise for me in one
sentence is how ill liberal they are i
always imagine they're liberal networks
no no i'm liberal okay in the sense that
like i believe in the enlightenment and
i i believe in the bill of rights and i
think we do have rights
um
they are not liberals they are defenders
of the powerful which is a much graver
sin like you can have silly politics i
get it i've had silly politics maybe i
do now people make mistakes
but defending the billionaire class
blaming everything on like working-class
white people who are like you know by
far
the most shafted people in america look
at the suicide rate look at the death
rate i mean it's like it's measurable
but everything's their fault
it's insane cnn ran a piece today saying
white supremacists are applauding the
taliban and it's like
okay uh you know i don't even know what
they're talking about
but but leaving that aside it's like
what are you really saying you're saying
the real problem with withdrawal from
afghanistan was not terrible decisions
that the buy administration made of the
pentagon made or that our entire foreign
policy establishment bipartisan made for
20 years now the real problem is some
guy in alabama who's got unauthorized
views it's like maybe you should stop
attacking these people because they are
the weakest people in our society and
you're doing it
in order to defend like the shittiest
people in our society but also the
richest and the most powerful you're the
praetorian guard for the most powerful
people like how can you live with
yourself if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell